how do you always keep a positive
mindset right and so people ask me this
question a lot because I got a paralyzed
right arm in hand right and it happened
kind of like the corona happened in
terms of not the actual incident but it
happened in terms of in my life when it
hit my life it came out of nowhere
right I didn't know that this could
happen I didn't know I could experience
a career-ending injury it just never
crossed my mind I've been playing
football since I was 7 years old right
and I loved it I loved every bit of the
game and so on September 9th 2006 when I
went out and I went to make a tackle and
it almost ended my life the next morning
I woke up it wasn't even about the game
of football at that point I was just
grateful that I was alive but I was just
grateful I could still see my family my
friends my mother my father right I was
just grateful for the gift of life right
I had a paralyzed ride home in hand but
I went to the Mayo Clinic and my first
day at the Mayo Clinic in Rochester
Minnesota when I sat down I was sitting
across from a young girl right and I
don't know what her medical condition
was right but I could tell she was
extremely young and when I looked at her
it was like her parents were sitting on
the side of her and they were trying to
help keep like skin up on her face right
and so when I went into my doctor's
visit and I met him I was like man I
just got a paralyzed right woman hand
right I just saw a young girl they had a
condition that was way worse than mine
right he's like that quote that says
when we complain about our problems when
we talk about our problems if we had a
chance to throw our problems in a pile
with somebody else's I'm sure we'll pull
our problems right back out and so when
when I talk to people about being
positive a lot of times they think I'm
being naive and I don't see the negative
side of things right I see it just like
everybody else sees it right but when I
look at it I just don't see how focusing
on it and complaining about it can help
me become the man that I strive to
become every single day right like I had
I had a saying with Cass that I that I
hang around and play with right now is
simple never complain about something
not willing to change because we see
people all the time they complain they
complain they complain and they never do
anything they never focus on a solution
and they never try to change it or they
never shift their perspective to do
anything different to extract certain
things from the opposition or the
adversity to have value to their lives
or other people's lives many of you just
like me probably in my business with Fit
Body Boot Camp and and all the other the
supplement company that we have a
software company every single business
has felt the pinch from this coronavirus
than the economic disaster that followed
with it but guess what you're either
gonna stay in the fight and reinvent
yourself and learn to pivot like we did
or you're just gonna wither up and die I
just want to tell you guys something
whether you've been working through the
weekend like I have or you've just been
waiting for Monday to come around you
can go back in the trenches go back to
the fight what you don't want to do is
wait there's no man on the white horse
that's kind of gallop in to save the day
there's no government thing that's gonna
come in and save you that's the reality
I know everyone's applying for that SBA
loan I get it do it do it and we
certainly are applying for some loans
ourselves but guess what I'm not gonna
wait for the loans to come through three
four five six weeks from now I've
already figured out new ways to make
money to pivot our Fit Body Boot Camp
franchises to online coaching to launch
our 28-day stronger together challenge
at-home challenge so that we can get
people at home fit at home right because
if I just wait for the government if I
wait for the virus to go away if I wait
for things to go back to normal that
might be waiting for a long time because
this is a new normal right now for us so
whatever your business is I don't want
you guys to think that things are gonna
be normal in two weeks and three weeks
and four weeks if they are great
fantastic awesome analyst let's rock but
if things are not normal in three weeks
four weeks then I want you to consider
this the new normal I want you to
consider this this is this this new new
economy an opportunity to make new types
of money maybe you're taking your
business online I've know so many people
like my kids school went online right
they're teaching school starting
tomorrow morning online on Google
Hangouts one young man that I mentor I
talked about a murder last week his name
is Layton he teaches skate lessons
outside of the skate park he
going online and his teaching it via
zoom and he's gonna teach whatever
tricks and strategies kids need to learn
with skates and put the skateboarding
and people are gonna do it
in fact my son Andrew trains with him
right get skate lessons from him and the
reality is the show must go on the
dude's got a wife he's got a kid he's
got to make money
our Fit Body Boot Camp franchises hey
guess what government tells us we got to
shut down every gym across the country
cool but unlike many other gyms around
there we're just not gonna cancel
memberships you're not gonna cancel
memberships and then go dark and then
think that someone else isn't going to
pick up those clients because businesses
like mine where we're pivoting to online
coaching we're gonna pick up those
clients we're gonna love them up and
we're gonna keep them after the doors
open and so I want you to think about
whatever type of business do you run I
got a friend who sells high-end homes
eight ten twelve twenty million dollar
home strat Southern California he's
doing virtual tours of those homes cuz
they ain't no one coming out of their
house to take a bird to take that
in-person tour right so many businesses
have gone online even you know think
about GrubHub and post me they're like
hey we figured it out we know what we're
gonna do we're gonna we're gonna let you
order and either pick up from your
favorite steakhouse
like tonight we're picking up steak from
are my favorite steakhouse
the dude sent out an offer and said if
you buy for two hundred dollar gift
cards you get a fifth two hundred dollar
gift card for free so I bought it from
my foreign leaders my four leaders on a
gosh I was going to surprise them but if
they're watching this and my readers are
my VP's are watching this right now you
four VP's are gonna get hooked up from
the Chop House and guess what the fifth
200 dollar card was on the Chop House so
I was like hey that's a smoking deal man
lay my leadership team has been working
super hard I want to reward them with
something and I get a two hundred dollar
gift card that I get to use tonight to
pick up steak and bring it home right so
every business can go online for the
most part and so I'm asking you what is
your pivot right now obviously
priority is your safety your physical
safety and mental emotional health and
health of your you know your loved ones
certain things you can control certain
things you can't control and I think
it's important to know what's going on
not absolutely think it's important to
know what's going on so you can make
decisions based on that
and also thing with your brain you have
part of your brain called that you make
the love and it gets hijacked when it's
a threat and it's hard right now with
everything when you're sprawling or
you're watching and everything is
centered on fear and fear serves a
purpose blood to be careful in my own
right now I should be afraid of them all
because that gives peace doing anything
EE in harm's way so fear is very useful
yeah also know that there's an algorithm
funds like gets around in your mind what
you focus on like if you like you know
the talking cat videos not Instagram
they start showing you more dog and cat
videos the same kind of their mind they
focus on what yours
what sun media all the time things that
can harm us I'm not saying we should you
should know it's my money but if you
overindulge of it your brain to start
showing you things challenge because
there's physical hygiene washing your
hair hands buddy there's also been
selection
are you keeping hearing or buying
straight man in here
times of turbulence weather whatever is
going on right now right now I'm in New
York City this is New York City on rush
hour it's so insane so it's a beautiful
day but there's um you know but it's
empty right now so my my goal here for
you my take on this is manage your mind
more more than ever you need to manage
your mind a lot of people are asking me
how is the co vid 19 actually affecting
me definitely in January I actually
emailed my family and then close
relatives to say hey this this thing
could be pretty pretty bad and pretty
big and I started seeing contracts of
speaking being cancelled but we know
that you know contracts come and go some
contracts were postponed some contracts
were how do you say cancelled but we
know that you know business is business
money is money money comes and goes and
I feel sorry for the small business
owners I feel sorry for the people who
are employees of the small business that
you're employed with and just want to
tell you I love you all keep on going
one day at a time most of the people
that I'm talking to saying that this is
gonna be a temporary thing where
everything should bounce back up I don't
know what the future holds but I just
want you to know keep on going and never
giving up what is true success to you
common question coming up to me for me
success is the enjoyment of the
consistent everyday
persistent without quick pursuit of my
potential in case you missed that one it
is absolutely the consistent persistent
pursuit of your potential and the
ability to smile through that struggle
smile through that pursuit remember
there is no sorry Chris Gardner there's
a good friend of mine there is no
pursuit of happiness happiness is the
pursuit you need to enjoy the pursuit
you have to love and learn to love what
you're doing and that's the key to this
entire journey the life lessons will
keep coming and they're gonna keep on
coming to you'll join them if you want
more advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right there next to me I
hope you find it valuable continue to
believe and I'll see you there
or community large it's important for us
to take care of our health